I can talk for hours about every single episode of How I Met Your Mother.
我可以谈论《老爸老妈浪漫史》的每一集几个小时。
And we do.
我们确实这么做了。
But when it comes to my own health, I used to be pretty clueless.
但当谈到我自己的健康时，我却一无所知。
I'd shrug off low energy, or a fitness plateau is just stress, basically guessing about what my body actually needed.
我会摆脱低能量，或者健身平台只是压力，基本上猜测我的身体实际需要什么。
But you shouldn't guess when it comes to your health.
但当涉及到您的健康时，您不应该猜测。
Instead, you should get the real data that supports your wellness with lab core on-demand health testing.
相反，您应该通过实验室核心按需健康测试来获取支持您健康的真实数据。
On the website, you can choose from a suite of more than 100 health tests, including micronutrient allergy, testosterone, fitness, sexual wellness, and more, all available to purchase without a doctor's appointment.
在该网站上，您可以从 100 多项健康测试中进行选择，包括微量营养素过敏、睾酮、健身、性健康等，所有这些都可以在无需医生预约的情况下购买。
Just purchase a test online, then visit a local lab core location to have your sample collected.
只需在线购买测试，然后访问当地实验室核心地点即可收集样本。
It's so simple.
就是这么简单。
Within days, you'll have accurate results that are easy to understand from a lab doctor's trust.
几天之内，您将获得实验室医生信任的易于理解的准确结果。
For your journey visit ondemand.labcore.com slash mother and use code Mother to save up to 15% on select tests.
对于您的旅程，请访问 ondemand.labcore.comlash mother 并使用代码 Mother 在精选测试中节省高达 15% 的费用。
That's ondemand.labcore.com slash mother and use code Mother.
这是 ondemand.labcore.com 斜线 mother 并使用代码 Mother。
Know yourself.
了解你自己。
Hey Craig, you know now that I have a child, a baby in the house, do you know what I'm finding it hard to do?
嘿克雷格，你现在知道我有一个孩子了，家里有一个婴儿，你知道我觉得做什么很难吗？
What?
什么？
To remember to do?
要记得做什么？
What's that?
那是什么？
Eat food.
吃食物。
but that's one of the basic needs that is no longer the priority.
但这是基本需求之一，但不再是优先事项。
I know, and I forget.
我知道，但我忘记了。
It's like, oh, I forgot to feed Nelson, my dog, and myself.
就像，哦，我忘了喂尼尔森、我的狗和我自己。
So how are we going to solve that problem?
那么我们要如何解决这个问题呢？
Well, I just need something just quick on the go that I won't, no must, no fuss.
好吧，我只是需要一些快速的东西，我不会，没有必要，不用大惊小怪。
I just need to feed myself and get some energy so I can get back to parenting.
我只需要养活自己并获得一些能量，这样我就可以回去养育孩子了。
Yes, and so what would solve that problem?
是的，那么什么可以解决这个问题呢？
I'm going to steer you towards an outcome and the outcome is this product you're about to mention.
我将引导您走向一个结果，而这个结果就是您将要提到的这款产品。
Oh, wait, are you talking about Bavarian meats, little lamb, yeager, snacks, sticks?
哦，等等，你是在说巴伐利亚肉类、小羊肉、耶格啤酒、零食、肉棒吗？
We agreed, that's what, right before we started talking to Zoe said, that's what we're gonna talk about.
我们同意，这就是我们开始与佐伊交谈之前所说的，这就是我们要谈论的内容。
Well, this is what I want to talk about.
嗯，这就是我想讲的。
The great tasting Bavarian meats, little lamb, yeager, snacks, sticks.
美味的巴伐利亚肉类、小羊肉、耶格啤酒、小吃、肉棒。
They sent us some of these and they are delicious and they solve the central problem of my life, which is I forget to eat.
他们给我们送来了一些，它们很美味，解决了我生活中的核心问题，那就是我忘记吃饭。
They're naturally fermented, They're made with real ingredients, slow smoked for bold flavor packed with nine grams of protein per serving, and have zero sugar and zero carbs.
它们是自然发酵的，采用真正的原料制成，缓慢熏制，味道浓郁，每份含有 9 克蛋白质，并且零糖和零碳水化合物。
Also, I have a 19 year old boy.
另外，我有一个19岁的男孩。
Also a good moment to get a bunch of this product because he will eat us out of house and home.
这也是购买一堆这种产品的好时机，因为他会把我们吃得满屋子和家里。
And he loves this stuff.
他喜欢这个东西。
It's so great.
太棒了。
I'm very grateful we got to sample this.
我非常感激我们能品尝到这个。
My son is gonna eat it all.
我儿子会把它全部吃掉。
I'm gonna have none of it.
我将一无所有。
But okay, it's a snack that keeps up with your day, whether you're racing between meetings or feeding babies or 19 year olds.
但没关系，无论您是在赶会议还是在给婴儿或 19 岁的孩子喂奶，它都是一款适合您一天的零食。
doing school drop off, just trying to finish your to-do list, take a moment to savor something delicious for you or your children.
放学时，只是想完成您的待办事项清单，花点时间为您或您的孩子品尝美味的东西。
And did we mention they're portable?
我们有没有提到它们是便携式的？
Toss a few in your glove box, your gym bag, the diaper bag, wherever.
在您的手套箱、健身包、尿布包中或任何地方都扔一些。
We have a diaper bag.
我们有一个尿布袋。
I bet you do.
我打赌你会的。
Two or three of those bad boys.
两三个坏男孩。
Pick up a pack today, your local grocer, or stock up at BavarianMeats.com slash podcast.
立即从当地杂货店购买一包，或在 BavarianMeats.com 斜线播客上购买。
Use code mother10mother10 at checkout for 10% off your first order.
结帐时使用代码 mother10mother10，首次订单可享受 10% 折扣。
The very meat snack sticks, great taste, zero sugar, to another bonus episode of how we made your mother that we liked to call general questions, general questions, I'm here with my friend Craig Thomas, hello Craig and our friend Alec Lev, hello Alec, hi, hi, so many are we are we loaded up with some general questions about purple giraffe episode two.
非常肉类的零食棒，味道很好，零糖，还有我们如何创造你的母亲的另一个奖励剧集，我们喜欢称之为一般问题，一般问题，我和我的朋友克雷格托马斯在这里，你好克雷格和我们的朋友亚历克列夫，你好亚历克，嗨，嗨，我们有很多关于紫色长颈鹿第二集的一般问题。
We are so many questions, hundreds of questions, keep them coming on Instagram, they're really amazing.
我们有很多问题，数百个问题，让它们不断出现在 Instagram 上，它们真的很棒。
And thank you, by the way, to our Instagramers who really stuck to questions about purple giraffe, which is the best thing.
顺便说一句，谢谢我们的 Instagram 用户，他们一直在追问有关紫色长颈鹿的问题，这是最好的事情。
Yeah, it needs to be about the episode.
是的，应该是关于剧情的。
That's the we've discovered.
这就是我们发现的。
I'm going to bunch a few together here.
我要把几个集中在这里。
But Josh, this is basically about you and Kobe.
但是乔什，这基本上是关于你和科比的。
We touched upon it on the episode, but people really want to hear about this.
我们在这一集中谈到了这一点，但人们真的很想听到这一点。
So Raven X moon and the Super Boyle ask about this as well as many other people.
所以 Raven X Moon 和 Super Boyle 以及许多其他人都询问了这个问题。
I'll read Raven X moons in terms of of your chemistry with Kobe Smolders.
我会根据你和科比·斯莫尔德斯的化学反应来读《Raven X Moons》。
This episode really solidifies Ted and Robbins dynamic.
这一集确实巩固了泰德和罗宾斯的活力。
How did you and Kobe develop that on-screen chemistry so early on?
你和科比是如何这么早就在银幕上产生化学反应的？
What was that like?
那是什么样子的？
A lot of people also asked like, what was like to kiss her?
很多人也问，吻她是什么感觉？
You didn't just meet her and stuff like that.
你不只是遇见了她之类的。
So sometimes people ask questions about being an actor that are like, I know that if you don't do it, those are the questions that would first occur to you.
所以有时人们会问关于成为一名演员的问题，比如，我知道如果你不这样做，这些就是你首先想到的问题。
Like, how do you remember all all those lines, but doing it, it's kind of like asking an accountant, like, how do you, how do you do all that math?
就像，你如何记住所有这些台词，但是这样做，有点像问会计师，比如，你如何，你如何做所有这些数学？
It's like, it's literally the job, like, it's actually the job.
就像，这确实是工作，就像，这实际上是工作。
So Kobe and I never once had a, if you have a conversation about your chemistry, you're killing the chemistry, like, it's an unspoken thing that you trust.
所以科比和我从来没有说过，如果你谈论你们之间的化学反应，那么你就是在扼杀化学反应，就像，这是你信任的一种不言而喻的事情。
We got cast because we have a thing between us that is alchemical and mysterious and just works when we're on screen together.
我们被选中是因为我们之间有一种东西，它是炼金术般的、神秘的，只有当我们一起出现在银幕上时才会发挥作用。
I always felt like we were acting, but I also felt like we were just truth like trying to get as truthfully under the characters as we could.
我总觉得我们在表演，但我也觉得我们只是在尽力真实地了解角色。
I don't, we never once had to talk about it and I don't, I think that was appropriate.
我不，我们从来没有谈论过它，我不，我认为这是合适的。
I think that was right.
我认为这是对的。
We shouldn't be talking about that.
我们不应该谈论这个。
decision.
决定。
I was like, if this isn't working, I assume they'll tell us.
我当时想，如果这不起作用，我想他们会告诉我们。
But it seemed to be working.
但它似乎正在发挥作用。
I think you have to trust that you were cast well.
我认为你必须相信你选得很好。
Sometimes I actually, you know, at this stage of my career, I get offers for things, but every once in a while, if you want something and they don't think you're right for it, you go in and you read for it.
事实上，你知道，有时在我职业生涯的这个阶段，我会收到一些东西的邀请，但每隔一段时间，如果你想要某样东西，而他们认为你不适合它，你就会进去阅读。
And sometimes I really like that because I want to let people know they hire the right person.
有时我真的很喜欢这样，因为我想让人们知道他们雇用了合适的人。
I mean, I would prefer offers out there, anyone listening.
我的意思是，我更希望有人愿意倾听。
But sometimes you want to go in and make sure that you're in a project that wants you and that you're the right guy for the role.
但有时你想进去并确保你所在的项目需要你，并且你是这个角色的合适人选。
You're the right actor for the role.
你是这个角色的合适演员。
So I just trusted that I was right for the role.
所以我只是相信我适合这个角色。
I knew Kobe was right for her role.
我知道科比非常适合她的角色。
And I think we were just trying to be as honest as we could.
我认为我们只是尽力诚实。
I don't think there was much that went into it.
我认为其中并没有涉及太多内容。
I mean, also kissing another actor is also feels curiously like just another day's work.
我的意思是，奇怪的是，亲吻另一位演员也感觉像是又一天的工作。
Like, I don't mean to, like, you're really kissing.
就像，我不是故意的，就像，你真的在​​接吻。
Like, you're not fake kissing.
就像，你们不是假接吻。
But you're, you know, I adore, at that time, it was her new boyfriend, and now her longtime husband, Terran.
但你，你知道，我崇拜的是，当时，是她的新男友，现在是她多年的丈夫，人族。
It's like, you don't have any illusions that you're actually going through these things.
就像，你对自己正在经历这些事情不抱任何幻想。
You're really doing a job.
你确实在做一份工作。
And I know that sounds kind of unsexy and maybe disappointing to people, but it's just the truth.
我知道这听起来有点不性感，也许会让人们失望，但这就是事实。
You just do it.
你就这么做吧。
And you laugh in between takes and you move on with it, you know?
你会在拍摄间隙大笑并继续拍摄，你知道吗？
Here's your proof that it did in fact work.
这是你的证据，证明它确实有效。
We milked it for nine fucking years.
我们挤了他妈的九年的奶。
So it did the dynamic did work just in case you tell you a funny story that I read.
所以它确实有效，以防万一你告诉你我读过的一个有趣的故事。
I read this great story.
我读了这个伟大的故事。
It was an interview with Emma Stone in, I don't know, Vanity Fair or something.
我不知道是《名利场》之类的节目对艾玛·斯通的采访。
And she's a young girl actress.
她是一位年轻的女演员。
I think it was before she had kind of had her maybe big breakthroughs or whatever with easy A or whatever.
我认为那是在她通过简单的 A 或其他方式取得重大突破或其他什么之前。
But she was doing a movie with Jeff Bridges and she, not Jeff Bridges, Jeff Daniels.
但她正在和杰夫·布里奇斯一起拍电影，而她，而不是杰夫·布里奇斯，是杰夫·丹尼尔斯。
And she had to cry.
她不得不哭。
She thought she had to cry in this scene and she couldn't cry, she couldn't get the tears.
她以为这一幕她必须哭，但她哭不出来，她哭不出来。
So he saw her afterwards and she was devastated, she was so upset, I blew it.
所以他后来看到了她，她很伤心，她很沮丧，我搞砸了。
What's wrong?
怎么了？
I didn't do it.
我没有做。
I didn't cry.
我没有哭。
And he said, Emma, you're not supposed to cry.
他说，艾玛，你不应该哭。
The audience is supposed to cry.
观众应该会哭。
They're gonna put some strings on the scene and everyone will cry.
他们会给现场加上一些绳索，每个人都会哭。
Like don't worry about it, it's not your job.
就像不用担心一样，这不是你的工作。
It's the audience's job.
这是观众的工作。
And I kind of feel that way about romantic scenes and it's like yeah, I throw myself into it and I'm doing my best, but you're the one that has the emotional response is the audience more almost than me.
我对浪漫的场景有这种感觉，是的，我全身心投入其中，我正在尽力而为，但你是比我更能引起观众情感反应的人。
If that I hope that's not devastating to people.
如果是这样，我希望这不会对人们造成毁灭性的影响。
I do it to take away some of the mystique, but that's it.
我这样做是为了消除一些神秘感，但仅此而已。
Hally Reewee asks Craig.
哈莉·雷威问克雷格。
I love how the ending bar scene of the episode rewind a date night was called back in the series finale, not much of a spoiler.
我喜欢这一集结尾的酒吧场景如何在系列结局中倒带约会之夜，没有太多剧透。
It's a line.
这是一条线。
The show was masterful at callbacks.
该节目在回调方面表现出色。
How did you keep track of things that you reference that you were to later bring back in future episodes?
你是如何记录你在以后的剧集中提到的那些东西的？
I think it's what Josh just said about kissing.
我想这就是乔希刚才所说的关于接吻的事情。
You sort of have to not overthink it and not force it.
你必须不要想太多，也不要强迫它。
I think those things come to you in the moment organically, like calling back a joke with a friend in a conversation, and you go, that feels right.
我认为这些事情会自然而然地出现在你的脑海里，就像回想起与朋友谈话中的一个笑话，然后你就走了，那感觉是对的。
Let's do it.
我们开始做吧。
We didn't have some file that was like, we should call all these things back.
我们没有类似的文件，我们应该把所有这些东西都回调回来。
Let's keep our running list.
让我们保留我们的跑步清单。
It's like, if it came to you in the moment.
就像，如果它在那一刻来到你身边。
Because a writer's room is an improv game, right?
因为作家的房间是一个即兴游戏，对吗？
You're in this room with all these people trying to go line by line, especially when you're punching up the script.
你在这个房间里，和所有这些人一起尝试逐行进行，尤其是当你敲打剧本时。
The script is on a bunch of computer screens around a table, you're looking at the lines all together.
剧本在桌子周围的一堆电脑屏幕上，你可以一起看台词。
You're kind of riffing in character, right?
你的性格有点即兴发挥，对吧？
You're kind of trying to think of what this character might say, and you need people who can kind of inhabit that and call that stuff out in real time.
你有点试图思考这个角色可能会说什么，你需要能够融入其中并实时说出这些内容的人。
Obviously, there's also the writing by yourself in a room part of the process, too.
显然，这个过程中也有你自己在房间里写作的一部分。
But I think those callbacks come when you're hanging out with a group of people, and somebody sparks and realizes this kind of echoes this earlier thing, and you bring it back.
但我认为，当你和一群人一起出去玩时，有人激发并意识到这种回声与之前的事情相呼应，你就会把它带回来。
And I think it's, again, something you almost don't want to pull too many threads up.
我认为这又是你不想拉扯太多线索的事情。
It always feels like a gift when you think of a really good callback because it's kind of a free joke because it's kind of, it's kind of already the joke you set up, but if the best callbacks twist it a little bit or reframe it in some way and this episode purple draft is, it's all callbacks because again, it is, it is this kind of ground hug day structure where you're kind of reliving the same party, although the party gets worse and worse and worse.
当你想到一个非常好的回调时，它总是感觉像是一份礼物，因为它是一种免费的笑话，因为它已经是你设置的笑话，但如果最好的回调稍微扭曲它或以某种方式重新构建它，而这一集紫色草稿是，这都是回调，因为再次，它是，这是一种地面拥抱日结构，你可以在其中重温同一个聚会，尽管聚会变得越来越糟。
But that's true.
但这是事实。
Ground hug day too.
地面拥抱日也是如此。
So it's great.
所以这很棒。
Ted has, this may be an episode, we should do this if you're an interesting statistic.
特德，这可能是一个插曲，如果你是一个有趣的统计数据，我们应该这样做。
Is this the highest rate of Ted saying the same line over and over and over?
这是 Ted 一遍又一遍地说同一句话的最高比例吗？
Because Ted has to say Ted says, so that was Robin.
因为泰德必须说泰德说的，所以那就是罗宾。
Ted says there's a bunch of repeat lines and callbacks and they get funnier and funnier.
特德说有很多重复的台词和回调，而且它们变得越来越有趣。
The more times they happen and this episode was a great example of that.
它们发生的次数越多，这一集就是一个很好的例子。
And I think it's just the form.
我认为这只是形式。
The form dictated it.
形式决定了它。
The three parties dictated callbacks.
三方决定回调。
Would you also say Craig, you have a writer's room.
你是否也会说克雷格，你有一个作家的房间。
You also have writer's your assistants who are like jotting down everything and keeping track.
你还有作家助理，他们会记下一切并进行跟踪。
You have a kind of hive mind, right?
你有一种蜂巢思维，对吗？
It is.
这是。
Yeah.
是的。
It's bigger than just your brain.
它比你的大脑还要大。
Yeah.
是的。
And that's, I feel like I can't say that enough times on this podcast, just how brilliant our writing stuff was and our writer's assistants are script coordinate.
也就是说，我觉得我不能在这个播客上说足够多次，我们的写作材料是多么出色，我们的作家助理是剧本协调者。
Everybody was, there was a mind meld, it was a hive mind and people would throw stuff out.
每个人都是，有一种思想融合，这是一种蜂巢思想，人们会扔掉东西。
And also like, you guys on the stage would think of things, Pam Fryman would think of stuff as a director.
而且就像，舞台上的你们会思考一些事情，帕姆·弗莱曼也会作为导演思考一些事情。
What if we echo back this moment, like, you have a big safety net.
如果我们回响这一刻，比如，你有一个很大的安全网，该怎么办？
You have a lot of layers of people who can think of those moments, too, and help out.
你有很多层次的人也可以想到这些时刻并提供帮助。
And everybody, there was such an immersive feeling to the creative team behind how I met your mother.
大家，在我遇见你们母亲的过程中，创意团队有一种身临其境的感觉。
It was a really, we were all sharing the same delusion in the greatest possible way.
这确实是，我们都以尽可能最大的方式分享着同样的错觉。
We were all living in that universe, feeling like we were part of it.
我们都生活在那个宇宙中，感觉自己是它的一部分。
And those callbacks just come.
这些回调就来了。
Those great moments come back organically in that setting.
那些伟大的时刻在那个环境中有机地回归。
There are a lot of questions, and you can take them you will that of course want to hear a little bit about your real life and how it connects to characters or story or theme like Andre underscore Nash 777 who'd like to know your favorite kind of dip.
有很多问题，你可以回答，你当然想听听一些关于你的现实生活，以及它如何与人物、故事或主题联系起来，比如安德烈强调纳什 777，他想知道你最喜欢的浸法。
That does talk about it.
这确实谈到了这一点。
My favorite kind of dip.
我最喜欢的浸法。
I mean probably my mom makes this she used to make it for I think Thanksgiving but like that spinach or artichoke thing which is mostly cheese.
我的意思是，可能是我妈妈做的这个，我想她以前是在感恩节做的，但喜欢菠菜或朝鲜蓟，主要是奶酪。
That's a good with some triskits.
搭配一些 trikits 就很好了。
Come on.
快点。
Oh yeah.
哦，是的。
That's delicious.
真好吃。
That is delicious.
那很好吃。
Oh yeah.
哦，是的。
Final answer.
最终答案。
Oh no.
哦不。
For me, my mother would make for holidays sour cream with French onion soup mix stirred in and that with a couple carrots and maybe a couple triskits was heaven on earth.
对我来说，我的母亲会在假期做酸奶油，拌入法式洋葱汤，再配上几根胡萝卜，也许还有几块三件套，那就是人间天堂了。
It may have been it's my mother's finest culinary moments.
这可能是我母亲最美好的烹饪时刻。
You know what?
你知道吗？
We both reference to our mothers.
我们都提到了我们的母亲。
We did.
我们做到了。
Oh my god, thematic.
天哪，主题。
Let me do an easy one for you, Josh.
让我为你做一个简单的，乔什。
So again, imagine people who don't know the way TV shows are made.
再次想象一下那些不知道电视节目制作方式的人。
Just Wallace XOX would like to know what you are drinking at the bar, assuming it is not actually beer.
只是 Wallace XOX 想知道您在酒吧喝的是什么，假设它实际上不是啤酒。
So when it was bottles of beer, it was always water because they were like you couldn't see what you know, they were either their green bottles or brown bottles.
所以当它是瓶装啤酒时，它总是水，因为它们就像你看不到你所知道的一样，它们要么是绿色瓶子，要么是棕色瓶子。
So it was almost always water.
所以它几乎总是水。
And then the fake beer was fake beer, right?
那么假啤酒就是假啤酒，对吗？
Like, wasn't it just like fake beer?
就像，这不是就像假啤酒吗？
You tell me I kind of, I don't remember.
你告诉我，我有点，我不记得了。
I don't even remember what it was on the show.
我什至不记得节目里讲了什么。
Was it fake beer?
难道是假啤酒？
Was it like sparkling?
是不是像闪闪发光？
I was like juice.
我就像果汁一样。
I mean, the only time we had real booze was at the close of the pilot.
我的意思是，我们唯一一次喝到真正的酒是在试播集结束时。
We drank champagne to celebrate.
我们喝了香槟庆祝。
But the rest of the time, I mean, we were in the middle of work days all the time, like, no one was- Hey, but have gone very, very poorly.
但剩下的时间，我的意思是，我们一直在工作日中间，就像，没有人 - 嘿，但是进展得非常非常糟糕。
They wouldn't have gone badly.
他们的情况不会很糟糕。
We were all ready to end our kick, you know?
我们都准备好结束我们的踢球了，你知道吗？
Hey, yeah.
嘿，是的。
And I wrote you this little ditty to sing to you in New York City.
我给你写了这首小曲，是为了在纽约唱给你听。
Snapple would like you to take a break from the sheds.
斯内普尔希望你能离开棚屋休息一下。
Those things you should be doing should be finishing, should be- thinking about well right now just uh crack open a snapple and just sit tight for a minute while Craig and I share some snapple real facts with you uh not unlike uh Mr. Mosby's fun facts.
你应该做的那些事情应该完成，应该——现在就想好，打开一个折扣，坐一会儿，然后克雷格和我与你分享一些折扣的真实事实，就像莫斯比先生的有趣事实一样。
Mr. Ted Mosby would have a lot of his fun facts.
特德·莫斯比先生会有很多有趣的事实。
He would love these and some of these are even architecture related so give us our first fact.
他会喜欢这些，其中一些甚至与建筑相关，所以请告诉我们第一个事实。
What do you guys?
你们做什么？
These all feel like things Ted or or at least like a future like dad Ted would say.
这些都感觉像是泰德所说的事情，或者至少像泰德爸爸所说的未来。
All right, here is a Snapple Real Facts, 253.
好吧，这是 Snapple 的真实事实，253。
The first TV remote control introduced in 1950 was called Lazy Bones.
1950 年推出的第一个电视遥控器被称为“Lazy Bones”。
I didn't know that.
我不知道。
I mean, I mean, either.
我的意思是，我的意思是，要么。
Real Facts, 1517 in New York.
真实的事实，1517 年在纽约。
It is illegal to sell a haunted house without telling the buyer.
在未告知买家的情况下出售鬼屋是违法的。
That's actually amazing.
这实际上是惊人的。
And that feels like a very, that feels like a very martial actually.
这感觉就像是一种非常非常武术的感觉。
These are weirdly resonant.
这些产生了奇怪的共鸣。
Okay, in fact, that is amazing and I want to know more but we don't have time for it in the snaple chat.
好吧，事实上，这太棒了，我想了解更多，但我们没有时间在 snaple 聊天中进行了解。
Real facts, 1978, 1,978 I'm gonna think has nothing to do with the year in 1978.
真实的事实，1978，1,978 我认为与 1978 年无关。
More than 40 buildings in New York have their own zip codes.
纽约有 40 多座建筑物都有自己的邮政编码。
That is totally a Ted Mosby fund that he would actually know that.
这完全是泰德·莫斯比（Ted Mosby）的基金，他实际上知道这一点。
He told every girlfriend that, snaple real fact, 1,667 lovebirds are actual birds.
他告诉每个女朋友，事实上，1,667 只爱情鸟都是真正的鸟。
actual birds.
真正的鸟类。
Boom, and we bring you back to love.
繁荣，我们让你重拾爱情。
It's all full circle.
这都是完整的循环。
It's all very himmyamy.
这一切都非常他妈的。
All right, that's your break.
好吧，这是你的休息时间。
Quick fun and just a little unexpected.
快速有趣，只是有点出乎意料。
Next time you hit pause and make a count with Snapple on your next break.
下次您按下暂停键并在下一次休息时使用 Snapple 进行计数。
Hi, I'm Alex Goldman, host of the HyperFixed podcast.
大家好，我是 Alex Goldman，HyperFixed 播客的主持人。
Each week, we take listeners problems and try to solve them for them.
每周，我们都会处理听众的问题并尝试为他们解决。
Problems like, I'm 30 and I'm scared to drive in New York.
比如，我已经 30 岁了，我害怕在纽约开车。
Or, why can't I adjust the volume of my car stereo when I'm in reverse?
或者，为什么我倒车时无法调节汽车音响的音量？
We also solve non-car related problems.
我们还解决非汽车相关的问题。
If you have a problem, not only will we fix it, we'll expose the hidden systems that cause that problem in the first place.
如果您遇到问题，我们不仅会修复它，还会首先暴露导致该问题的隐藏系统。
That's the HyperFixed Podcast from Radio Topia.
这是来自 Radio Topia 的 HyperFixed 播客。
Find it wherever you find podcasts or at HyperFixedPod.com.
无论您在哪里找到播客或在 HyperFixedPod.com 上都可以找到它。
The Ale, Josh.
啤酒，乔什。
Remember those legendary freezer pops from childhood summers?
还记得童年夏天那些传奇的冰柜汽水吗？
You know the one I'm talking about.
你知道我正在谈论的那个人。
The red, white, and blue ones.
有红的、白的、蓝的。
It is the only thing I remember from childhood.
这是我从小到大唯一记得的事情。
That's right.
这是正确的。
pretty much ruled the neighborhood pools and playgrounds.
几乎统治了附近的游泳池和游乐场。
Your face would be covered with your finger.
你的脸会被你的手指遮住。
It was just a delightful summer memory.
这只是一个愉快的夏日记忆。
Well, five hour energy has taken that iconic nostalgia and reimagined it as a bold, refreshing, firework freeze energy shot.
嗯，《五小时能量》将这种标志性的怀旧情绪重新想象成大胆、清爽、烟火般的定格能量镜头。
Every single sip delivers a massive flavor explosion like the original pops of which you speak, expertly blending, juicy cherry, citrusy lime, and sweet blue raspberry to completely ignite your taste buds.
每一口都会带来巨大的风味爆炸，就像您所说的原始流行音乐一样，巧妙地混合了多汁的樱桃、柑橘酸橙和甜美的蓝覆盆子，完全点燃您的味蕾。
It's that fruity taste that you crave created with zero sugar so you can enjoy the full experience guilt-free.
这是您渴望的零糖果味，这样您就可以无负罪感地享受完整的体验。
Whether you're conquering a packed schedule, tackling a mid-afternoon slump at your desk, headed out on a weekend road trip or just looking to spark a vibrant new flavor sensation, This portable shot is the perfect daily companion.
无论您是要克服繁忙的日程、解决午后在办公桌前的困倦、周末公路旅行还是只是想激发一种充满活力的新风味感觉，这款便携式镜头都是完美的日常伴侣。
Give your routine an exciting upgrade with a mouth-watering twist on a timeless favorite.
为您的日常生活带来令人兴奋的升级，为永恒的最爱带来令人垂涎的变化。
Ignite your taste buds with a firework freeze flavored five-hour energy shot now available online at fivehourenergy.com or Amazon.
现在可以在 Fivehourenergy.com 或 Amazon 上购买烟花冷冻口味的五小时能量饮料，点燃您的味蕾。
This is a matter of one.
这是一回事。
Underscore, generic underscore asks, was there any difference between the mood in filming the pilot and the mood filming this episode to Purple Giraffe.
Underscore，通用的下划线询问，拍摄试播集的心情和拍摄紫长颈鹿这一集的心情有什么不同吗？
I always imagine that's the kind of real pilot since the show has been picked up at this point.
我一直认为这才是真正的试播集，因为这部剧现在已经开始播出了。
We talked a little bit on the full episode about how you as a person were sort of handling this.
我们在整集中讨论了一些关于你作为一个人是如何处理这个问题的。
Do you remember?
你是否记得？
Can you feel what it was like being on that set together of like, oh, we're doing it.
你能感觉到在那个片场在一起的感觉吗，就像，哦，我们正在做这件事。
We're doing this, yeah.
我们正在做这个，是的。
I think when you're shooting the pilot, you're like, this might just be a great week we all spend together.
我想当你拍摄试播集时，你会想，这可能是我们一起度过的美好一周。
Yeah.
是的。
Like just one week of our lives.
就像我们生命中的一周。
That's kind of fun.
这很有趣。
and then maybe we'll run into each other years later or work together again.
然后也许几年后我们会相遇或者再次合作。
Once the show is picked up and you're like, okay, they bought, they want 13.
一旦这部剧被收看，你就会想，好吧，他们买了，他们想要 13 个。
We'll see how this goes.
我们会看看事情进展如何。
There's at least the feeling that you can breathe a little deeper that you can settle in with these people a little, like, okay, it's gonna be a couple months at the very least.
至少有一种感觉，你可以深呼吸一点，你可以和这些人一起安顿下来，就像，好吧，至少需要几个月的时间。
So I don't know, what do you think, Craig?
所以我不知道你怎么看，克雷格？
Yeah, I mean, my mind goes immediately to like, should we put up posters in the office?
是的，我的意思是，我立刻想到，我们应该在办公室张贴海报吗？
Should we?
我们应该吗？
So I bring in family photos, how much do I put in this desk?
所以我把全家福都带来了，我在这张桌子上放了多少钱？
How comfortable do we get?
我们有多舒服？
And I think there was a little bit of that.
我认为有一点这样的情况。
There was trying to figure that out.
有人试图解决这个问题。
A pilot is inherently not that.
飞行员本质上不是这样的。
It might just be a week, like Josh said.
就像乔什说的那样，可能只是一周。
We knew we had 13 of them.
我们知道我们有 13 个。
We had one plus 12.
我们有一加12。
And so you're trying to believe it's gonna go and go and go.
所以你试图相信它会消失、消失、消失。
And you're trying to invest in, you're trying to feather this nest that the intention is to spend at least 100 episodes and it turned out to be more than double that.
你试图投资，你试图让这个巢穴，你的目的是花费至少 100 集，结果却是这个数字的两倍多。
But I remember that it's a dance, it's a dance.
但我记得那是舞蹈，那是舞蹈。
How do I act like these are my people?
我该如何表现得像这些人是我的人一样？
Are these my people for the next decade of my life?
这些是我生命中下一个十年的人吗？
Are these gonna become my family?
这些会成为我的家人吗？
Do I let myself be in that way?
我会让自己变成那样吗？
Do I trust that?
我相信吗？
It's like a relationship.
这就像一种关系。
It's like, okay, I'm excited about this relationship.
就像，好吧，我对这段关系感到兴奋。
I don't want to get too excited about it.
我不想对此太兴奋。
It could blow up in my face.
它可能会在我脸上爆炸。
It could be taken away from me immediately.
它可以立即从我身边夺走。
So you're trying to be judicious with your emotions, I think, in some ways.
所以我认为，在某些方面，你正试图明智地对待自己的情绪。
It's a hope test.
这是一个希望的考验。
It's kind of like the Shawshank Redemption, Like the philosophical like is it is hope a good thing or not?
这有点像《肖申克的救赎》，就像哲学上的希望是好事还是坏事？
How can you allow yourself to hope?
你怎么能让自己充满希望？
And I remember feeling very full of hope and very excited.
我记得我感到非常充满希望并且非常兴奋。
And yet that there's a neurotic part of my brain.
然而我的大脑中有一个神经质的部分。
It's like, don't, don't lean into it too much.
就像，不要，不要过度依赖它。
You could all disappear.
你们都可以消失。
But mostly I remember feeling like this, this feels right.
但大多数时候我记得这样的感觉，这种感觉是对的。
This feels like it's going to go.
这感觉就像是要过去一样。
A lot of people would love to hear about the roof in, in many ways, underscore less way and swarly memes.
很多人都喜欢在很多方面听到有关屋顶的信息，强调较少的方式和粗暴的模因。
By the way, shout out to swarly memes who does a huge account on Instagram.
顺便说一句，要向在 Instagram 上拥有庞大账户的 swarly meme 大声喊叫。
Great on Instagram and follow that if you're a himium fan.
在 Instagram 上很棒，如果您是 Himium 粉丝，请关注它。
Yeah, that's a great one.
是的，那是一件很棒的事情。
They've been really supportive of the show on the tail a a a they want to hear all about the the roof.
他们非常支持尾部的节目，他们想听听有关屋顶的一切。
Did either of you have something you'd equate to the roof?
你们中的任何一个人有没有相当于屋顶的东西？
What was the inspiration for the roof?
屋顶的灵感是什么？
And did you ever do anything crazy for someone like Ted did for Rob?
你有没有像泰德为罗布那样为某人做过疯狂的事？
And I know we're getting sort of personal questions here.
我知道我们在这里收到一些个人问题。
But does that spark anything this this this nutty idea of this special place, the roof, and why you chose that as a New Yorker, perhaps, rooftop, please.
但这是否会激发任何关于这个特殊地方的疯狂想法，屋顶，以及为什么你作为纽约人选择屋顶，请。
Yeah, I mean, for the choice from a rating perspective was we wanted it to feel like New York.
是的，我的意思是，从评级的角度来看，我们希望它感觉像纽约。
We thought of that rooftop set as like a go-to semi-regular set.
我们认为屋顶布景就像是首选的半常规布景。
So we really sweated, like we really, like, and again, our DP, our cinematographer, and our set designer, or Steve Olson, we said, we're going to be here a lot.
所以我们真的出汗了，就像我们真的一样，再一次，我们的摄影指导、我们的电影摄影师和我们的布景设计师，或者史蒂夫·奥尔森，我们说，我们会经常来这里。
Spend some time on this, really you need to design this.
花一些时间在这上面，你真的需要设计这个。
This is going to be a regular place that we go.
这将成为我们经常去的地方。
And it was because we've all been to those rooftop parties in our 20s.
这是因为我们二十多岁的时候都参加过那些屋顶派对。
We wanted it to feel like you go up on the roof in New York City and things just feel magical.
我们希望感觉就像你登上纽约市的屋顶，一切都感觉很神奇。
It just does.
确实如此。
There's something that happens.
有事情发生了。
It's like you've climbed through some portal into some other place and there's something magical about being in a roof in New York City.
就好像您已经通过某个门户爬到另一个地方，而在纽约市的屋顶上有一种神奇的感觉。
It doesn't matter where, if it's a fancy building, if it's the exact opposite.
不管是在哪里，无论是一座漂亮的建筑，还是完全相反的建筑。
There's something about being a roof in New York that is so evocative of your youth and your 20s in New York.
作为纽约的一个屋顶，总能让你回想起年轻时和二十多岁时在纽约的生活。
And we couldn't get to that roof fast enough.
我们无法足够快地到达那个屋顶。
If we could have got it in the pilot, we would have got there, but episode two where we're getting to that roof in these parties.
如果我们能在试播集中得到它，我们就会到达那里，但在第二集中我们将在这些聚会中到达屋顶。
And there's also something about living in New York like any sort of roof space is like really fancy and luxury.
在纽约生活还有一种感觉，任何类型的屋顶空间都非常华丽和奢华。
It's like there's chimneys and air conditioning units up there that are loud and annoying.
就像上面有烟囱和空调一样，声音很大，很烦人。
I remember, I think it was Seth Meyers last special where he talked about we have a nice New York apartment.
我记得，我想这是塞思·迈耶斯最后一次特别节目，他谈到我们在纽约有一套漂亮的公寓。
If you're not from New York, you come over and you go, this is a nice apartment.
如果你不是来自纽约，你过来然后走，这是一套不错的公寓。
If you are from New York, you come over and go, this is a great apartment.
如果你来自纽约，你过来又走，这是一套很棒的公寓。
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
是啊，是啊，是啊。
There's a standard.
有一个标准。
So we have outdoor space.
所以我们有室外空间。
Our outdoor space in Ohio would be not that impressive, but in New York, it's quite lovely.
我们在俄亥俄州的户外空间不会那么令人印象深刻，但在纽约，它非常可爱。
And I think like it's a very, it was a very specific New York roof top where it's like you got to climb out on the fire escape, but it's a little bit dangerous to get up there.
我认为这是一个非常非常特殊的纽约屋顶，就像你必须从消防梯爬出去一样，但爬到那里有点危险。
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
是啊，是啊，是啊，是啊。
It feels a little bit like, if you're too drunk on that roof, you got to be real careful.
感觉有点像，如果你在屋顶上喝得太醉了，你就必须非常小心。
Yes, it's a little dangerous, it's a little dirty, it's a little danger, but it's, it's magic.
是的，它有点危险，它有点肮脏，它有点危险，但它是，它是魔法。
And I remember it being very important to us, like, you have to see sky.
我记得这对我们来说非常重要，就像，你必须看到天空。
We wanted that feeling of seeing sky because out the window of the hero apartment of, like, of Ted and Marshall and Millie is you see a building across the way because we didn't want it to be like, you know, the there was always that thing of like, how could they afford that apartment on friends?
我们想要那种看到天空的感觉，因为在泰德、马歇尔和米莉的英雄公寓的窗外，你可以看到对面的一座建筑，因为我们不希望它就像，你知道，总是有这样的事情，他们怎么能在朋友身上买得起那套公寓？
You know, you see with that like great view out the window of Sky, we thought, this will go, we'll go realistic.
你知道，你看到天空窗外的美景，我们想，这一切都会过去，我们会变得现实。
Carter and I live in an apartment in 75th Street when we used to read for Dave Letterman.
卡特和我住在 75 街的一间公寓里，我们曾经为戴夫·莱特曼读书。
You looked out the windows and you saw a building.
你向窗外望去，看到了一栋大楼。
So it was not high up.
所以当时的地位并不高。
It was not fancy.
这并不花哨。
We said, let's go for that.
我们说，我们就这么做吧。
Move and Steve Olsen want to do that too.
Move 和 Steve Olsen 也想这么做。
It's like, they live in an apartment that just looks out at buildings.
就像，他们住在一间只能看到建筑物的公寓里。
So he said, but we need Sky.
他说，但我们需要天空。
We need to see Skyline.
我们需要看看天际线。
the magic New York City rom-com skyline.
神奇的纽约市浪漫喜剧天际线。
So he said the way if there's just buildings out the window of the apartment, the roof has to be, the rooftop has to be a character or a recurring character.
所以他说，如果公寓窗外只有建筑物，那么屋顶就必须是，屋顶必须是一个角色或一个反复出现的角色。
And the roof becomes an important playing ground, you know.
你知道，屋顶成为了一个重要的游乐场。
That's where Ted Howles at the Heavens and makes it rain.
特德就是在那里向天空咆哮并下雨的。
That's the leaping, you know, from roof to roof, whatever that.
你知道，这就是从一个屋顶到另一个屋顶的跳跃，不管是什么。
Yeah, the leap.
是的，飞跃。
The leap.
飞跃。
Yeah, yeah.
是啊是啊。
The leap.
飞跃。
Yeah.
是的。
In the finale, they're up on the I mean, that roof is such a character in the show.
在结局中，他们站在了我的意思是，那个屋顶就是剧中的一个角色。
And so much of so many of their memories take place up there.
他们的很多记忆都发生在那里。
It's great.
这很棒。
Ted and Robin have so many great moments up there.
泰德和罗宾在那里度过了很多美好的时刻。
Okay, a lot of people just wanted to mention, of course, Carlos, I'll say Kyle Vallo too, mentioned like what he became.
好吧，很多人只是想提一下，当然，卡洛斯，我也会说凯尔·瓦洛，提到他成为了什么。
Just talk a little bit about casting about casting, people who are there for a day or two, and what the process of that is like.
就简单谈谈选角、选角、在那里呆一两天的人，以及选角的过程是怎样的。
Well, it's a funny process because you want to get someone great for this side part and you have this foolish optimism that the episode won't be wildy long and you'll keep all of their jokes.
嗯，这是一个有趣的过程，因为你想要找一个很棒的人来扮演这个配角，并且你有一种愚蠢的乐观情绪，认为这一集不会太长，你会保留他们所有的笑话。
In episode two of any show, you're just trying to sell the audience who these five characters are.
在任何节目的第二集中，你只是想向观众推销这五个角色。
And it's such a disservice to the other side actors in that episode.
这对该集中的其他配角演员来说是一种极大的伤害。
One of whom happens to be John Brinthol, who's going to have a huge career and he's great.
约翰·布林索尔（John Brinthol）就是其中之一，他的职业生涯将会非常辉煌，而且他非常出色。
And we had to chop out a bunch of the stuff we shot with him, no fault of him.
我们不得不删掉一些和他一起拍摄的东西，这不是他的错。
There was bits for Carlos, there were more things for Carlos in the episode.
这一集里有卡洛斯的片段，还有更多关于卡洛斯的东西。
And the first cut of the episode was, you know, one third too long.
你知道，这一集的第一个剪辑太长了三分之一。
It was, you know, 30 minutes, it should have been 20 minutes, basically.
你知道，那是 30 分钟，基本上应该是 20 分钟。
And Carlos had to suffer and lose a bunch of his jokes.
卡洛斯不得不遭受痛苦并失去了很多笑话。
And that is just, that is a really good example of one of many of how we were just finding the recipe for this thing.
这只是一个很好的例子，说明我们如何找到这件事的秘诀。
Still, right?
还是，对吧？
You have four days to shoot a pilot not we and how much whether once we're in series We shot these episodes in three days.
你有四天的时间来拍摄试播集，而不是我们，一旦我们进入连续剧，我们会在三天内拍摄这些剧集。
You almost always Upied the pilot because it's a pilot and you're finding it and you want more time You do four full days This was us doing the first three-day shoot.
你几乎总是升级试播集，因为它是一个试播集，你正在寻找它，你想要更多的时间。你花了整整四天时间，这是我们第一次为期三天的拍摄。
You got to get through that shoot that much faster That's a day shorter than the pilot and then you have to edit it and turn it around and post it And get it to be exactly the right time in a hurry and we learned that lesson the hard way and we learned it over and over again The whole series every episode of this podcast you will hear me say I wish we had five extra minutes.
你必须更快地完成拍摄，这比试播集要短一天，然后你必须编辑它，翻转它并发布它，并在匆忙中让它在正确的时间，我们以惨痛的方式吸取了这一教训，我们一遍又一遍地学习整个系列的每一集，你会听到我说我希望我们有额外的五分钟。
We cut this thing, we cut that thing.
我们砍这个东西，我们砍那个东西。
We never fully learned the lesson.
我们从未完全吸取教训。
We always overshot, so we got a little better as we went, but that's, so John Bernthal, great, and he's wonderful and apologies to him because we certainly had more good stuff of his and we had to, of course, focus on our five characters.
我们总是超越，所以我们做得更好一点，但那就是，所以约翰博恩塔尔，很棒，他很棒，并向他道歉，因为我们当然有他更多的好东西，当然，我们必须专注于我们的五个角色。
John was, I remember him back from New York, even in LA, we, I think got out of school around the same year, and when you get, When you have a good enough agent, you end up on this kind of audition circuit for all these shows, for all these movies, and you end up in these waiting rooms with the same guys who are like in your class.
约翰，我记得他从纽约回来，甚至在洛杉矶，我们，我想大约在同一年就离开了学校，当你得到，当你有一个足够好的经纪人时，你最终会参加所有这些节目，所有这些电影的试镜巡回演出，并且你最终会和你班上的那些人一起在这些候诊室里。
I was in so many waiting rooms with John that we ended up having lunch once or twice, just because we were leaving at the same time.
我和约翰在很多候诊室里，最后我们吃了一两次午餐，只是因为我们同时离开。
So when he came back on the show, I was like, he was like my old friend from my auditioning days.
所以当他回到节目中时，我想，他就像我试镜时的老朋友一样。
I did not know that.
我不知道。
Yeah, yeah.
是啊是啊。
But it was so fun to see him and it's been so great to watch him like have such a killer career He's a great actor.
但见到他真是太有趣了，看到他拥有如此杀手级的职业生涯真是太棒了，他是一位伟大的演员。
No, he's cleared.
不，他已经清白了。
He did.
他做到了。
I'm so happy for his career because he's really charismatic and interesting.
我为他的职业生涯感到非常高兴，因为他真的很有魅力而且很有趣。
And of course, that, you know, people found that over and over.
当然，你知道，人们一遍又一遍地发现这一点。
And he's got a huge curse and something's great.
他有一个巨大的诅咒，而且有些东西很棒。
Josh, I was going to say, are we going to talk about acting process, but we've got 207 more of these to go.
乔什，我本来想说，我们要谈谈表演过程吗，但我们还有 207 个这样的事情要做。
So I hope we do.
所以我希望我们能做到。
I'm going to tie this question into that if I could.
如果可以的话，我会把这个问题与这个问题联系起来。
Stephanie Goldstone asked about the wardrobe choices of all the characters.
斯蒂芬妮·戈德斯通询问了所有角色的服装选择。
He talks about Barney and his suits.
他谈论巴尼和他的西装。
We talked a little bit about suits in the last episode.
我们在上一集中讨论了一些关于西装的话题。
We'll talk more suits, I'm sure, in the future.
我确信，将来我们会讨论更多的诉讼。
Can you talk a little bit about Ted's wardrobe?
你能谈谈 Ted 的着装吗？
Ted's costume, and what that does for you as an actor, how much it influences your like, yeah, just put it on, or it's like, oh, Oh, it's this.
泰德的服装，以及它对你作为演员的作用，它对你的影响有多大，是的，穿上它，或者就像，哦，哦，就是这个。
Now I now I feel a new thing.
现在我现在有了新的感觉。
Yeah, I mean, it's interesting in a show that is set, you know, in the modern.
是的，我的意思是，这部以现代为背景的剧很有趣。
I mean, it was, it's a flashback show, but it was like, it was, we were playing 2005 as 2005, right?
我的意思是，这是一个闪回节目，但它就像是，我们把 2005 年当作 2005 年来玩，对吧？
So I did notice that Ted's blazer had a real strong shoulder like real structured kind of shoulder.
所以我确实注意到特德的西装外套有一个真正坚固的肩部，就像真正结构化的肩部一样。
I think, you know, I, I, I am a weird strange, like I did this show Hunters on Amazon and I was playing like in 1970s coked up movie star Nazi hunter.
我想，你知道，我，我，我是一个奇怪的人，就像我在亚马逊上表演的《猎人》一样，我扮演的就像 20 世纪 70 年代吸毒的电影明星纳粹猎人一样。
And I wore outrageously cool, interesting 70s wild clothes, but it was because I was in the character of that.
我穿着极其酷炫、有趣的 70 年代狂野服装，但那是因为我就是这样的角色。
Like I could never pull off those clothes in my life, but I could as the character.
就像我这辈子永远无法脱掉那些衣服一样，但我可以作为角色。
Because I was playing Ted, who was more, he was like closer to me, like biographically and age-wise and even his sense of style, I never drifted that far from my own sense of style.
因为我扮演的是特德，他更接近我，从传记和年龄来看，甚至他的风格感，我从来没有偏离自己的风格感那么远。
However, I think I'm a little like sloppier than him, like I, I, he was more like buttoned up than me.
不过，我觉得我比他有点邋遢，像我，我，他比我更保守。
Like the, the, the, the, I mean, obviously TV is always ironed or whatever, but you know, he wore blazers.
就像，我的意思是，显然电视总是熨烫的或其他什么，但你知道，他穿着西装外套。
There was something always like, professorial about his look.
他的外表总有一种教授般的气质。
What's that line that really, it was in the Mandy Moore episode, you'll remember this crag where Barty has a thing like Ted has a classic look that never goes out of style season to season.
曼迪·摩尔 (Mandy Moore) 剧集中的那句台词到底是什么，你会记得在这块峭壁上，巴蒂 (Barty) 的造型就像泰德 (Ted) 一样，有着经典的造型，每一季都不会过时。
Or do you remember what he like, talks about, Ted's more, you know, yeah, yeah, we'll see it soon.
或者你还记得他喜欢什么，谈论什么，泰德更多，你知道，是的，是的，我们很快就会看到。
I don't remember if I made him, but yes, I like the line.
我不记得是否是我创造了他，但是的，我喜欢这句台词。
Yeah, we'll get there.
是的，我们会到达那里。
I think there was something, he's not the most adventurous guy when it comes to his sartorial choices.
我认为有一点，在服装选择方面，他并不是最有冒险精神的人。
Is that the right word?
这个词用得对吗？
Yeah.
是的。
That was a very good word.
这是一个非常好的词。
Extra points.
加分。
Yeah, but I thought I, I, I, I never would wear something that I, that was out of the question that I would wear.
是的，但我想我，我，我，我永远不会穿我不可能穿的东西。
Although sometimes you look back, you're like, that's a dated shirt.
尽管有时候你回头看，你会想，那是一件过时的衬衫。
I think I'll see some.
我想我会看到一些。
I'm going to see some.
我要去看看一些。
There was a phase where they were putting, uh, lily and robin and kind of like a lot of like satin tops that they kind of rebelled against.
有一个阶段，他们穿上了，呃，百合和知更鸟，还有很多类似缎面的上衣，他们有点反抗。
And then they were putting a lot of like western shirts, like sometimes had a little western thing going on.
然后他们穿了很多类似西部风格的衬衫，就像有时会发生一些西部风格的事情。
Like I feel like in season two, there was a bunch of that.
就像我觉得第二季里有很多这样的事情。
It was season two.
那是第二季。
It's kind of like bold, weird, like designs down like one and a half of it.
它有点像大胆的、奇怪的，就像设计下降了一半。
Yeah.
是的。
And I was like, okay, I'll trust them.
我当时想，好吧，我会相信他们。
But then I looked back and I was like, I should think I think there's going to be some tough moments.
但后来我回想起来，我想，我应该认为会有一些艰难的时刻。
it's coming up.
它即将到来。
You got this podcast rewatching some of those, you have so many clothing changes.
你重新观看了这个播客中的一些内容，你有很多衣服的变化。
So like me and Jason, like, we would wear the same pants for like a whole episode, like the same jeans and shoes.
所以就像我和杰森一样，我们会在整集里穿同样的裤子，就像同样的牛仔裤和鞋子。
So we would just change out our shirts and put on, you know, like we change on set, like in.
所以我们会换掉衬衫然后穿上，你知道，就像我们在片场换衣服一样。
You just start changing in front of everyone because you don't want to walk that all the way back to the dressing room.
你只是开始在所有人面前换衣服，因为你不想一路走回更衣室。
Seagull, but didn't go to dressing room once, and you'll never really change in front of everyone.
海鸥，但一次也没进过更衣室，你永远不会在众人面前真正改变。
Yeah.
是的。
came a very, yeah, it was very much like a locker room.
非常，是的，它非常像更衣室。
No, it became so normal that you guys would just be disrobing and it was good.
不，这变得太正常了，你们会脱掉衣服，这很好。
We needed that because we had so many fricking scenes and flashbacks and jump around.
我们需要这个，因为我们有太多该​​死的场景、闪回和跳跃。
It's like, I'm not going to change my pants for this one.
就像，我不会为此换裤子。
Jason always said the most important thing he was most impressed with by me was when we would wear suits right to put on a tie that I could put on a tie without a mirror.
杰森总是说，他对我印象最深刻的最重要的事情就是我们穿西装打领带，而我可以在没有镜子的情况下打领带。
Just standing there and he was absolutely floored by it.
只是站在那里，他就彻底被震撼了。
Oh my God, that's really funny, that's really funny.
天哪，这真是太好笑了，这真是太好笑了。
Let me ask you about Jason and Ali or about Marshall and Lily.
让我问你关于杰森和阿里的事，或者关于马歇尔和莉莉的事。
This is even more so, I'd say, than the first episode though tied to it.
我想说，这比第一集更重要，尽管与之相关。
I think both the first and second episodes gives you, they're giving you little flavors of these two and it's a very different kind of television relationship that it's young but very established.
我认为第一集和第二集都给了你这两集的一些味道，这是一种非常不同的电视关系，它很年轻，但非常成熟。
You know, now they'll go through their rocky times, but often they'd be the Sam and Diane character, they'd be the, let's get these two together, that you're starting with them, not just kind of together, but deeply together, but very young, and also the show is very sexual and very filthy right from the beginning, but we're just getting hints of them.
你知道，现在他们会经历他们的艰难时期，但通常他们会是萨姆和黛安的角色，他们会是，让我们把这两个人放在一起，你从他们开始，不仅仅是在一起，而是深深地在一起，但非常年轻，而且这部剧从一开始就非常性感和非常肮脏，但我们只是得到他们的暗示。
Can you talk a little bit about Marcel and Lily, and where they were in the pilot, how are you starting to think about them here episode two.
你能谈谈马塞尔和莉莉吗？他们在试播集中的位置，你在第二集中是如何开始思考他们的？
We liked the idea of showing a couple that really enjoyed each other.
我们喜欢展示一对真正彼此喜欢的情侣的想法。
And it was not the beckersons.
而且不是贝克森一家。
It was not they're going to be fighting.
他们并不是要打仗。
You're going to watch like them having these marital spats, but in then in the end, they make up.
你会看到他们在婚姻中发生争吵，但最终他们会和好如初。
Of course, that happened.
当然，那件事发生了。
Things like that happen sometimes in the show, but we thought the default setting for these two is they love each other.
类似的事情在节目中有时会发生，但我们认为这两个人的默认设置是他们彼此相爱。
Their partners, their partners in crime, they're going to go through stuff together.
他们的伙伴，他们的犯罪伙伴，他们将一起经历一些事情。
They're going to be in the same page a lot of the time.
他们很多时候都会在同一页面上。
They're going to genuinely be amused and delighted by each other.
他们会真正地被彼此逗乐和高兴。
Let's have the fuel for them be, they have all of this history and they want Ted to catch up to them.
让我们为他们提供动力，他们拥有所有这些历史，他们希望特德能赶上他们。
They want Ted.
他们想要特德。
They also, they want Ted to find the right person so they can double day.
他们还希望特德找到合适的人，这样他们就可以双休。
They want to find the one for their own selfish reasons of having people to double day with because this was true.
他们出于自私的原因想找到一个可以与人共度一天的人，因为这是事实。
My wife and I got together very young and you couldn't find anyone to go out with on a double day because everyone's love life was in fucking shambles because they were 25 and we'd been together since freshman year of Wesleyan, and it was really hard.
我和我妻子很年轻的时候就在一起了，你找不到任何人可以一起出去玩，因为每个人的爱情生活都他妈的一团糟，因为他们才 25 岁，我们从卫斯理大学一年级就在一起了，这真的很难。
You rooted for couples to survive and last, like they seem cool.
你支持夫妻能够生存和长久，就像他们看起来很酷一样。
I hope they stay together.
我希望他们能一直在一起。
I want them to be like our couple friends and then it wouldn't happen.
我希望他们像我们的情侣朋友一样，这样就不会发生这种情况。
There's something funny about when you become, when you find the person you really want to be with, it's such a big thing that's been kind of solved.
有趣的是，当你找到那个你真正想在一起的人时，这件事就已经解决了。
I don't know if that's the right word, but it's like, it's one of the biggest choices you make.
我不知道这个词是否正确，但它就像是你做出的最大选择之一。
And you have all this energy that used to go into searching or, you know, even like your social energy is mostly predicated on maybe I'll meet someone and then we meet someone and you're like, it's eight thirty.
你拥有过去用于搜索的所有能量，或者，你知道，即使你的社交能量主要取决于也许我会遇到某人，然后我们遇到某人，你就像，现在是八点三十分。
Let's get into bed and read, like that just happens very quickly.
让我们上床读书吧，就像这一切发生得很快一样。
But there's something funny about the energy that it gets put into like, who can we set our friends up with?
但它所投入的能量有一些有趣的地方，比如我们可以把我们的朋友和谁联系起来？
Like, for some reason, couples love, like, Jordan and I do this, we're like, what about know is like you turn into these yenta match makers immediately when you get married.
就像，出于某种原因，情侣喜欢，就像，乔丹和我这样做，我们就像，知道就像你结婚后立即变成这些日元媒人一样。
It's a zombie movies.
这是一部僵尸电影。
Zombies want to make more zombies.
僵尸想要制造更多僵尸。
That's not the most flattering thing I've ever said about couplehood, but you know what I mean.
这不是我对夫妻关系说过的最讨人喜欢的话，但你知道我的意思。
You won company.
你赢得了陪伴。
Yeah.
是的。
And it's a part of the day.
这是一天的一部分。
No, it's true.
不，这是真的。
I also thought one of the great things, one of the great visual metaphors for Marshall and Lily was the no look high five.
我还认为马歇尔和莉莉最伟大的事情之一，最伟大的视觉隐喻之一就是不好看的高五。
Oh yeah.
哦，是的。
Yeah.
是的。
that's a metaphor for their relationship.
这是他们关系的一个隐喻。
It's really true.
这是真的。
Anytime we can write a joke where the joke implied shared history like the bunk bed joke in the pilot or even guys bound that joke in proposal of guys boundaries.
任何时候我们都可以写一个笑话，其中的笑话暗示着共同的历史，就像飞行员中的双层床笑话一样，甚至男人们在提出男人的界限时限制了这个笑话。
I loved how you delivered that Josh because it was like Ted has had to say Ted has said guys boundaries hundreds of times to them over the past six years of knowing never however many years more.
我喜欢你如何表达乔希，因为这就像泰德不得不说的那样，在过去的六年里，泰德已经对男人们说了数百次界限，但无论如何，他都知道了。
And I love jokes that imply that history and they are the parents.
我喜欢暗示历史和他们是父母的笑话。
They are the parents that the kids are grossed out that but the parents still like each other.
他们是孩子们厌恶的父母，但父母仍然互相喜欢。
Ted is the kid, all the other friends are the kids, and they're like, oh God, I think our parents are still fucking, this is terrible.
特德是个孩子，所有其他朋友都是孩子，他们就像，天哪，我想我们的父母还在他妈的，这太可怕了。
And it's like, but they love each other.
就像，但他们彼此相爱。
God damn it, it's a good thing.
该死的，这是一件好事。
Now, I have to say that by far, the most questions came in, and we touched on in the original episode, in the real episode about this episode, but let's talk about a little bit more, and I'll expand it out a bit.
现在，我不得不说，到目前为止，出现了最多的问题，我们在原始剧集中，在关于这一集的真实剧集中谈到了这一点，但让我们再讨论一点，我会稍微扩展一下。
I'll give Flynn Higney the question.
我将向弗林·希格尼提出这个问题。
This was the start of the purple versus yellow theory.
这是紫色与黄色理论的开始。
Can you explain it?
你能解释一下吗？
So I'm sure you've heard this phrase before online the purple versus yellow theory that this is a thing.
所以我确信您之前在网上听说过这句话，紫色与黄色理论认为这是一件事。
And you talked a little bit about in the episode we released a couple of days ago about the difference between the fans' experience of the show and your experience of writing it and of creating it.
您在我们几天前发布的剧集中谈到了粉丝对节目的体验与您编写和创作节目的体验之间的差异。
And especially this many years on, I find this really interesting that it's, I don't wanna say, of course it's okay.
尤其是这么多年过去了，我发现这真的很有趣，我不想说，当然没关系。
It's not just okay that the fans are creating a mythology or finding mythology or asking important questions, but it's the whole point of it.
粉丝们创造神话、寻找神话或提出重要问题这不仅仅是可以接受的，而且这就是它的全部意义。
It's the whole point of hanging a picture, the art on the wall.
这就是在墙上挂一幅画、一件艺术品的全部意义。
The artist doesn't get to hang out and tell people, no, no, it doesn't mean that it's this.
艺术家不会出去闲逛并告诉人们，不，不，这并不意味着就是这样。
That's what they're there for, but can you talk?
这就是他们在那里的目的，但是你能说话吗？
Everyone wants to know about it.
每个人都想知道这件事。
Everyone wants to know the purple versus yellow theory, but then expand that out to just how you were seeing things from the inside.
每个人都想知道紫色与黄色的理论，然后将其扩展到你如何从内部看待事物。
Can you lay out what this person's and I don't know what this theory is, is yellow theory is, just I've heard some talk of it, but I don't know that I have my mind all the way around it.
你能列出这个人的想法吗？我不知道这个理论是什么，是黄色理论吗？我只是听过一些谈论，但我不知道我是否有自己的想法。
I think that actually that's an important thing.
我认为这实际上是一件重要的事情。
I don't either, but there are dozens if not hundreds of questions that simply put it out that way.
我也不知道，但有数十个甚至数百个问题都只是以这种方式提出来的。
It's over and over.
一遍又一遍。
It's the purple versus yellow theory.
这是紫色与黄色理论。
This is the beginning of the purple versus yellow theory.
这是紫色与黄色理论的开始。
So I guess this, that almost answers the question.
所以我想这几乎回答了问题。
Well, I think we have to study up because I've heard it talked about.
嗯，我认为我们必须学习，因为我听说过它。
I think I've looked into people's descriptions of it before, but it's definitely, it's definitely something people are retroactively putting on the show.
我想我之前已经研究过人们对它的描述，但这绝对是人们在节目中追溯的东西。
I love it because I think that destiny, when we think about destiny or fate, we're always looking back and putting some spins on some things, right?
我喜欢它，因为我认为命运，当我们思考命运或命运时，我们总是会回顾并对某些事情进行一些调整，对吗？
Some of it was actually things we made happen.
其中一些实际上是我们促成的。
Some of it was some magical spark in the universe, and I also think you write things and you don't fully know what they mean when you write them and then you look back on it and you're like, oh, there is a lot of examples of this one phenomenon happening where this color popping up or if you think about it, this color I attracted, this color and this thing didn't, this, this, this propelled and like there are these weird laws of physics that emerge that you don't necessarily intend as you're writing it, but there's something to it.
其中一些是宇宙中的一些神奇的火花，我也认为你写了一些东西，当你写下它们时，你并不完全知道它们的含义，然后你回头看，你会想，哦，有很多这种现象发生的例子，这种颜色突然出现，或者如果你想一想，我吸引了这种颜色，这种颜色和这个东西没有，这个，这个，这推动了，就像出现了这些奇怪的物理定律，而你在写作时不一定是有意的它，但它有一些东西。
It sounds very woo-woo, but there is then- I know what you mean.
听起来很呜呜，但是还有——我知道你的意思。
Your brain, your subconscious is doing things you're not quite consciously aware of, But let me, I just asked Claude.
你的大脑，你的潜意识正在做一些你不太有意识地意识到的事情，但是让我来说，我刚刚问过克劳德。
Can I tell you what Claude said?
我可以告诉你克劳德说了什么吗？
Please.
请。
I said, what is the purple versus yellow theory for how I made your mother fans?
我说，我是如何让你妈妈成为粉丝的，紫黄理论是什么？
Claude says, let me address this while keeping in mind.
克劳德说，让我牢记这一点。
It's a fan theory from how I made your mother.
这是我塑造你母亲的粉丝理论。
The purple versus yellow theory relates to the color symbolism used throughout the series, particularly regarding the mother and Robin.
紫色与黄色理论与整个系列中使用的颜色象征有关，特别是关于母亲和罗宾。
Throughout the show, yellow is consistently associated with sh**.
在整部剧中，黄色始终与“嘘”联系在一起。
She carries a yellow umbrella, has yellow buses and important scenes, and is often shown with yellow imagery.
她撑着黄色的雨伞，乘坐黄色的巴士和重要的场景，并且经常以黄色的图像出现。
Meanwhile, purple blue tones are frequently associated with Robin.
与此同时，紫蓝色调经常与罗宾联系在一起。
She often wears these colors and they appear in scenes focused on her relationship with Ted.
她经常穿着这些颜色的衣服，并且它们出现在以她与泰德的关系为中心的场景中。
Fans notice this color coding and develop the theory that the show's creators deliberately use these colors to subtly hint at the series eventual ending.
粉丝们注意到了这种颜色编码，并提出了这样的理论：该剧的创作者故意使用这些颜色来巧妙地暗示该剧的最终结局。
This color theory gained particular attention after the series finale as fans look for clues.
在剧集大结局后，随着粉丝们寻找线索，这种色彩理论受到了特别关注。
Okay, we won't go into that.
好吧，我们不讨论这个。
I should note I should note that while I strive to be accurate in my response, since this involves fan theories interpretations, this may have evolved into online communities, you might want to verify specific details with him and fan communities or official sources.
我应该指出的是，虽然我努力做到准确回答，但由于这涉及粉丝理论解释，这可能已经演变成在线社区，您可能需要向他和粉丝社区或官方消息来源核实具体细节。
Were official sources, right, Craig?
是官方消息来源吗，克雷格？
We are.
我们是。
I think we count as official sources.
我认为我们算是官方消息来源。
We can verify that we weren't so clever as to think ahead of time.
我们可以证实我们并没有聪明到提前思考。
These will be, this will be this long game, this incredibly thought-out, like long-term plan.
这将是一场漫长的比赛，这是一场深思熟虑的比赛，就像长期计划一样。
But certainly we were very big on color coding characters.
但我们确实非常注重对字符进行颜色编码。
Well, in some ways, in some ways, this theory is a testament to all these other easter eggs you put throughout the show because people like you really did bury a lot of interesting stuff in there to be kind of for people to make connections and have these aha moments around.
嗯，在某些方面，在某些方面，这个理论证明了你在整个节目中放置的所有其他复活节彩蛋，因为像你这样的人确实埋藏了很多有趣的东西在那里，以便人们建立联系并度过这些顿悟时刻。
So of course, it would lead to them thinking, well, yeah, they color coded the two women.
所以当然，这会导致他们思考，嗯，是的，他们对这两个女人进行了颜色编码。
Yeah, and we did, I mean ultimately there was this kind of like yellow bright shiny thing that Ted was chasing through New York and seeing glimpses of it and it was and it was like that was her energy and also Robin who had a very different energy than a different kind of place and Ted's life and was these sort of different colors.
是的，我们做到了，我的意思是，最终有一种黄色明亮闪亮的东西，泰德在纽约追逐，瞥见了它，这就是她的能量，罗宾的能量与不同的地方和泰德的生活非常不同，是这些不同的颜色。
I was just saying we endorse this theory.
我只是说我们赞同这个理论。
Like I'm a fan of the theory.
就像我是这个理论的粉丝一样。
I like the theory.
我喜欢这个理论。
I don't know how conscious it was.
我不知道它的意识如何。
Emerged more subconsciously than as something planned, but I think there is very much something to the theory.
比计划中的事情更多是在潜意识中出现的，但我认为这个理论有很多东西。
How We Made Your Mother Is Hosted and Executive Produced by Josh Radner and Craig Thomas.
《我们如何创造了你的母亲》由乔什·拉德纳和克雷格·托马斯主持并监制。
The show was produced by me, Alec Lev, and our co-producer is Doug Matica.
该节目由我 Alec Lev 制作，我们的联合制作人是 Doug Matica。
Our audio producer and mixer is Alex Reeves at Pointe de Blue Studios, artwork by John Morrow.
我们的音频制作人和混音师是 Pointe de Blue Studios 的 Alex Reeves，作品由 John Morrow 创作。
Please follow, rate, and review the show on Apple Podcasts or your podcast player of choice.
请在 Apple 播客或您选择的播客播放器上关注、评分和评论该节目。
It really does help the show.
对节目确实有帮助。
Our theme song is NYC by our own Josh Ragnar, special thanks to Lola Kennedy and Elliot Connards.
我们的主题曲是我们自己的 Josh Ragnar 创作的《NYC》，特别感谢 Lola Kennedy 和 Elliot Connards。
Visit howwemagearmother.com to sign up for our substack mailing list and And for links to our social media, you can also click on the contact page to send us an email or a voice message.
请访问 howwemagearmother.com 注册我们的 substack 邮件列表，并获取我们社交媒体的链接，您还可以单击联系页面向我们发送电子邮件或语音消息。
Your stories and questions are an important part of the show.
您的故事和问题是节目的重要组成部分。
Subscribe to Josh Riders' newsletters on Substack, read Craig Thomas' published prose at Craig ThomasRider.com, and you can subscribe to my dead father's society also on Substack.
在 Substack 上订阅 Josh Riders 的时事通讯，在 Craig ThomasRider.com 上阅读 Craig Thomas 发表的散文，您还可以在 Substack 上订阅我已故父亲的社团。
To learn about how you make a difference, this shows ongoing campaign to raise money for for a congenital heart disease research.
要了解您如何做出改变，这展示了正在进行的为先天性心脏病研究筹集资金的活动。
Check out the Make It Difference tab at the top of our website.
查看我们网站顶部的“Make It Difference”选项卡。
This episode was made possible by the support of backyard ventures marketing provided by Tink Media.
这一集的成功得益于 Tink Media 提供的 Backyard Ventures 营销支持。
People will, in fact, dance.
事实上，人们会跳舞。
Real question, it just hit me.
真正的问题，它刚刚击中了我。
Am I in love with you or just knew your city?
我是爱上你了还是只是了解你的城市？